der un-generalsekretär antonio guterres
hat zum auftakt der un-generaldebatte
vor einem winter des weltweiten unmuts
gewarnt die staatliche übernahme des
angeschlagenen gasimporteurs uniqa steht
offenbar unmittelbar bevor und damit
herzlich willkommen zu viel nach 8
einiges deute abend sind sie kennen ihn
schon cdu-politiker und kanzler der
herzen wolfgang boss weil ich freue mich
sehr herzlich sicher die den ist
realisierung deutschlands gefährdet den
sozialstaat wir werden sehen ob das
stimmt moderatorin und unternehmerin
charlotte würdig beschäftigt die
verstärkte abtreibungsregeln ungarn sie
sieht die gefahr eines rechtsrucks in
europa fdp-generalsekretär bücherei
treibt die energiekrise um seine
forderung die drei sicheren
atomkraftwerke müssen am netz bleiben
last but not least nz politikredakteur
und villach stammgast alexander kissler
er will heute abend über die migrations
krise aufklären er findet es nämlich
merkwürdig dass niemand über diese
spricht bevor ich nur mit meiner these
staaten gibt es heute aber erstmal einen
buchtipp und zwar das neue buch von
wolfgang bosbach ich kann es ihnen sehr
empfehlen ist noch nicht auf dem markt
kommt aber jetzt der titel wer glaubt
uns noch warum politik an vertrauen
verliert und was wir dagegen tun können
sie wissen ich empfehle ich so oft
bücher dass sie habe ich aber schon
gelesen am wochenende und sie sollten es
auch tun prädikat lesenswert meint
hierzu heute abend ist aber eine andere
auch wenn ich gerne überall bosbachs
buch sprechen würde aber sie ist er
tagesaktuell und das ist stoppt die
masken pflicht für unsere alten ich weiß
ich sollte endlich mit dem thema masken
aufhören wir raten auch schon freunde
ich sei vielleicht etwas verfolgt von
den masten und ich glaube sie haben auch
recht ich verstehe dass sich die
menschen sorgen um mich machen aber ich
habe sehr wenig verständnis dafür dass
nicht alle bürger beim anblick der
masken losen politiker auf dem
oktoberfest auf die barrikaden gehen
während es kinder gibt die den schulen
mit maske sitzen müssen es ist ja
wahnsinn was in diesem land vorgeht aber
was für mich besonders grotesk ist die
menschen in altenheim werden zur maske
wieder gezwungen und das wie ich ja dann
von ihren eigenen vier wänden
schließlich leben sie ja dort diese
regelung gilt ab dem ersten oktober 2022
und zwar für die bewohner von
alteneinrichtungen pflegeeinrichtung in
einer zeit in der länder wie england
frankreich oder amerika die pandemie für
beendet erklärt haben begründet wird das
mit dem schutz der wohngruppen aber ich
möchte einmal reinhören die
justizminister marco buschmann uns das
denn erklärt warum ist dieses paket maß
voll das einzige was ja wir für den
herbst winter über das hinaus was
bekannt ist qualitativ wirklich als
bundesgesetzgeber einheitlich anordnen
sind ja die höheren sicherheitsstandards
in den krankenhäusern und in
altenpflegeheimen das einzige als
einzige was überhaupt noch passiert ist
es ja mal so nebenbei erklärt ist also
die situation in altenheim und ich
konnte natürlich nicht drum herum hier
direkt die frage ein händler
reinzustellen der ist ja der
generalsekretär der fdp hexerei ist es
denn überspitzt wenn ich sage dass die
bewohner in alten- und pflegeheim also
maske bei sich zu hause tragen müssen
also zunächst einmal muss ich den
kollegen buschmann verteidigen
sie dürfen nicht vergessen mit wem er
verhandeln musste er hat mit herrn
lauterbach verhindert sie kennen die
position der fdp
doch es sind schon sehr viele erfolge
erzielt worden aber in einer welt wo die
fdp die absolute mehrheit hätte
würde vermutlich ein mit sicherheit ein
infektionsschutzgesetz anders aussehen
als heute aber hier musste mit herrn
lauterbach
verhandelt werden wir sind in einer
koalition
da müssen auch konsens lösungen zustande
kommen und das ist halt das was man
gemeinsam vor allem der hat man dem 1
lauterbach ich muss kurz unterbrechen
kann man dem lauterbach nein ich muss
kurz noch da hat man im lauterbach also
als geschenk die alten gegeben so wie
ich vielleicht das buch von herrn
bosbach jetzt
dass sie heute hier ist es gibt es gibt
ja eine ganze reihe von entwicklungen
die auch stattfinden wer hätte
beispielsweise vor kurzem gedacht dass
beim thema maske im flugverkehr sich was
tun wird dann gab es dann diese bilder
wohl eine empörungswelle erkennbar war
und plötzlich war man zugänglich für die
argumente der fdp die man vorher
komplett ignoriert hatte und sie haben
ja auch eingangs diese bilder vom
oktoberfest gezeigt ich bin nicht
glücklich über diese bilder ich habe
also der politiker trage ich meine jetzt
kein bestimmtes bild will ja auch jetzt
niemanden kritisieren nur es ist immer
auch schwierig für das ansehen der
politik wenn man dinge beschließt aber
nach außen der eindruck entsteht die
stehen selbst nicht dazu und dann haben
wir ein problem beim thema
glaubwürdigkeit der politik aber noch
einmal für uns war völlig klar wir sind
in einer neuen phase der pandemie die
instrumente die in der vergangenheit
möglicherweise funktioniert haben die
gelten heute nicht mehr und es war uns
als fdp unheimlich wichtig zu sagen wir
wollen alle instrumente der ersten phase
der pandemie einmal evaluieren einmal
bewerten damit die wissenschaftsbasierte
möglicherweise auch überlegungen
entwickelt werden können für eine
mögliche neue welle oder neue phase der
pandemie feine sache war für uns dann
besonders wichtig wir haben gesagt
freiheitseinschränkung so im
voraus wird es nicht geben und das
prinzip der verhältnismäßigkeit muss
hochgehalten werden
dann haben wir haben das bei jeder
gelegenheit gesagt nicht die freiheit
muss begründet werden sondern die
einschränkung ja dann somit sind wir
auch in dieser diskussion trotzdem
befürchten eröffneten dann noch mal
wirklich die frage haben sie stellen ich
finde wirklich und hier wird wirklich
schlecht dabei wenn ich daran denke dass
also eigentlich jeder jetzt endlich mal
ohne maske rumlaufen darf aber die
alten- pflege- und altenheim die sollen
die maske aufsetzt und seinem sieht wie
ein was sie sehen doch gerade dann
völlig die völlig falsche person an der
stelle also ich weiß nicht wie viele
einladungen lauterbach geschickt haben
mal hier in dieser sendung ja aber dann
sollte man diese leute dann und die
fragen stellen also wir war diejenigen
die bei diesem thema beim
infektionsschutzgesetz für gegen die
freiheitseinschränkung kann also wurde
monaten vielleicht in heidenheim
pflegeeinrichtung noch mal es ist ich
will das jetzt nicht in einer sendung im
fernsehen auf machen etwas was in der
koalition vereinbart dann werde ich auch
in verdammt miese generalsekretär aber
jeder der in den letzten wochen monaten
sich die position der fdp an geschaut
hat weiß ganz genau mit welcher haltung
die fdp diese verhandlungen reingegangen
ist und es ist einfach nicht realistisch
von der fdp zu erwarten dass man sich
hundertprozentig dann auch durchsetzt
die mehrheit haben wir leider noch nicht
dann frage ich einmal herrn bosbach wie
sehen sie das denn die empfinden sie das
mit blick auf die pflege und altenheim
das ja die bewohner quasi in den eigenen
vier wänden zur maske gezwungen werden
es tun möchte der mark ist tun aber ich
bin gegen einen zwang und
eigenverantwortung die eigene
verantwortung weil die situationen in
den alten wohn und pflegeheimen sich
sehr ähneln und dürft mama ist in einer
solchen einrichtung geht die stramm auf
dem 595 lebensjahr zu ist geimpft die
pflegekräfte tragen alle masken wenn der
arzt kommt trägt er eine maske und du
darfst mutter nur besuchen wenn du dich
vorher hat es testen lassen und zwar 24
stunden vorher nicht irgendwann also ein
relativ hoher
sicherheitsstandard und
ich glaube man wird todunglücklich sein
der zu hause keine maske getragen obwohl
er kam der mobile pflegedienst angaben
der marseiller gaben der arzt kam der
friseur der haushaltshilfe
hat ist nichts passiert in allen all der
zeit ich glaube für mama wäre es eine
wirkliche belastung denn erst jetzt erst
an zu weinen ist pflichtbewusst tun
möchte mag es tun also flugzeug hat mich
jetzt ebenso positiv überrascht wie
gewundert denn im zug sitzt du ja viel
enger flugzeug sitzt du viel enger als
im zug dann wird gesagt aber der
luftaustausch in einem flugzeug ist
intensiver als in einer bahn
bei der letzten fahrt waren wir zu zweit
im abteil zu zweit und der kollege der
20 meter von ihr entfernt
ist aufgefordert worden doch bitte die
maske zu tragen hat ein getränk bestellt
und hat dann so von 0,24 stunden
gebraucht weil ich die maske an haben
wollte also wegen mir hat also ich hab
so brav getragen wir können uns gar
nicht erlauben die haben wir müssten
dann auch vorbild sein
als politiker nicht erfolgt wenn sie
sagen mit zwei leuten in der bayern
wissen sie was ich mache es nicht mehr
näher regeln sind dafür da dass man sie
einhält und wenn wir es nicht tun wie
können wir es dann erwarten
sagen die leute werden sagen wir können
sich als generalsekretär mehr
herausnehmen als wir kann man nicht weil
er unter verschärfter öffentlicher
beobachtung da steht ob es sinn haft ist
dahinter mal ein dickes fragezeichen
aber sagen sie es doch ruhig wenn ich
alleine entschieden hätte ich es nicht
gemacht aber wir mussten uns der
koalition wollte so ist das leben
mussten wir auch früher na ja wir haben
ja auch einiges durchgesetzt also ist
jetzt nicht so dass herr lauterbach sich
durchgesetzt hat also es ist ja schon
wie gesagt wir haben mit herrn
lauterbach
sagen
naja wahrscheinlich schon sagen keine
lockdown mehr keine schulschließung mehr
also das sind ja dinge das wird heute
als selbstverständlich dargestellt
glauben sie mir als jemand der die
verhandlungen mit bekommen hat das war
nicht selbstverständlich frau würde die
nehmen sie denn die aktuelle lage in
deutschland war bezüglich der korona
mengen ab dem ersten oktober erst einmal
viel durcheinander und erst einmal
tatsächlich
erstmals lese ich mir das jetzt durch
oder warte ich noch mal zwei wochen weil
sie ändert sich sowieso alles also man
hat so ein bisschen den
die die lust verloren sich damit
wirklich auseinanderzusetzen natürlich
atme ich auch als zweifach mutter wenn
ich lese es gibt keine schulschließungen
mehr glaube ich nein das muss ja jetzt
irgendwas passieren und dann gereicht
natürlich eine andere
wort oder andere handlung dass man sagen
jetzt müssen wir doch die schulen
schließen nichtsdestotrotz möchte ich
das letzte vertrauen natürlich nicht
verlieren was im moment sowieso
schwierig ist generell betrachtet
und deshalb bin ich auch froh dass man
überhaupt von der regelung gekommen ist
und was altersheime betrifft natürlich
wäre das wahnsinnig traurig wenn die
alten menschen dort im altersheim masken
tragen bis es liegt an uns wenn wir in
ein altersheim vertreten dann haben wir
eine maske zu tragen wir haben uns
vorher testen zu lassen dann können wir
dafür sorgen dass die da eine gute
normale zeit haben das liegt ganz an uns
für dich also sind auch dagegen dass die
bewohner von alf sicherheit um bastian
daran und das irgendwann reicht's auch
mais ist irgendwie also das ist genauso
wie die entscheidung fünftletzter seinen
masken tragen aber viel klässler nicht
ich habe jetzt aufgegeben bestimmte
sachen sind das sagen wir es nicht
verstehen haben sie auch ihre meinung in
manchen sachen geändert sie hatten ja
letztes jahr für furore gesorgt als sie
gegen die ungeimpften haben sie gesagt
in den würden sie das nicht weihnachten
feiern wollen haben sie da auch ihre
meinung geändert oder hat ihn der
verlauf krone hat sich auch verändert
auch gezeigt dass man seine meinung
ändern kann ich habe das nie gesagt ach
so ja das hat mir geschrieben
man muss dazu sagen hatten also das
steht nicht zwischen uns oder so aber
fakt ist einfach ja gesagt ich würde ich
hatte corona mit meinen beiden jungs
zusammen zu hause zwei wochen und das
war die absolute hölle und das möchte
ich niemandem zu trauen der sich nicht
hat impfen lassen falls ich noch
ansteckend sein sollte ach so das ist
ehrlich gesagt wirklich was anderes ja
immer ganz anderer fakt ja ja absolut
ich habe also absolut werden nehmen wer
sich nicht impfen lassen möchte sollte
halt nicht tun also dass es dann darum
kann ich mich auch noch kümmern deswegen
also auch da eigentlich das prinzip
freiheit und eigenverantwortung in
reiden verantwortung klar das ist immer
leicht gesagt das muss man natürlich
auch irgendwie auch leben und also man
sollte sich schon ein beispiel nehmen um
ein bisschen gucken und überlegen wo man
lebt was man macht wie soll man das
brauchte dass das auf jeden fall schon
weg ist ja wie sehen sie das denn das
infektionsschutzgesetz erster oktober
auf twitter sind sehr sehr rege gegen
die korona maßnahmen unterwegs definitiv
also natürlich hat jetzt der kollege von
der fdp jetzt hier alle hat die
verhandlungserfolge der fdp im angesicht
des übermächtigen dreimal groß gut
haften karl lauterbach geschildert aber
im ergebnis es ist natürlich immer noch
einen schritt hinter den freiheitsgraden
zurück die eigentlich vernünftig wäre
ich meine wenn selbst der amerikanische
präsident joe biden der was weiß ich 67
78 jahre alt ist 78 glaube ich sagt die
pandemie ist vorbei dann gibt es
eigentlich für keine einzige
einschränkung mehr einen vernünftigen
grund mehr und wenn ich höre dass sogar
im infektionsschutzgesetz das egt als
maßvoll maßvollen kompromissen anpreisen
drin gestanden hat bis vor der
verhandlung im bundesrat das kurbelt 19
eine reihe aufzuführen sei mit mit
scharlach glaube ich mit scharlach
kollaps verhindert worden ganz schlimme
krankheiten wurde später aber noch
verhindert nachdem es bereits auch die
rolle erklären bewegen gewissermaßen
gehabt hatte also ich meine man kann
immer sagen wir haben das schlimmste
verhindert da stimme ich ihnen also ein
land in dem karl lauterbach regieren
würde wäre ich schon ausgewandert
richtig dennoch ist es natürlich auf
lange sicht für eine selbstbewusste
partei auch wenn sie nur die kleinen ist
innerhalb einer kollektion etwas zu
wenig zu sagen wählt uns weil wir das
schlimmste verhindern ich glaube etwas
mehr traut dann muss man manchmal schon
geben und man sieht den momentan auch
dass die menschen sich an viele vorgaben
intuitiv nicht mehr zu halten wie es im
infektionsschutzgesetz steht
infektionsschutzgesetz steht gesetz
steht ich habe heute auch gemerkt in der
u bahn berlin tragen vielleicht 60 70
prozent noch die maske sven glaub ich
jede woche 56 prozent weniger was haben
wir dann von einem gesetz für eine
verordnung das schleichen in der
realität beerdigt wird weil es keine
binde kraft mehr hat ich will ja nicht
ich will ja nicht sagen jeder soll jetzt
rumrennen und sagen danke fdp aber
hätten sie einmal waren aber man muss
schon anerkennen dass seitdem die fdp in
der regierungsverantwortung ist eine
andere pandemie politik in deutschland
herrscht naja sollten fair sein und
jugendlichen gerade über die an die
impfpflicht debatte erinnert welche
partei hat das letztendlich für
aber aber entschuldigung aber trocken
ich frage mich auch manchmal was eine
erwartungshaltung hier gegenüber der fdp
formuliert werden das ist absolut nicht
realistisch noch mal wir haben nicht die
absolute mehrheit
wir haben eine geile nannte fanden die
politik in diesem land etabliert als
bisher existiert hatte nur einfach mal
weil die gar nicht mehr dann diese
erwartungshaltung ist dass die fdp in
der regierung genau das macht was sie im
wahlkampf versprochen wird dass in
deutschland wird erwartet dass sogar es
mich dass sie das ist sogar was die
erwartungshaltung des publikums geht vor
allen parteien meine sorge ist eine
andere ich gehe mal davon aus dass wir
mit der ende mit der endemischen
empfehlung leben müssen natürlich dass
wir aber dann niemals herauskommen aus
den schutzmaßnahmen wenn es immer wieder
neue fälle geben wird so wie es trotz
grippe schutzimpfungen immer wieder
grippe account hat nie gesagt
wir sind die übergang von der bande
mieter zu einer endemischen
entwicklungen wenn wir das zum maßstab
machen so lange wir noch kohle- oder
fillern nennenswerte zahlen müssen wir
immer schutzmaßnahmen ergreifen das ist
meine befürchtung dass wir dann aus dem
kreislauf nicht mehr herauskommen